hunger
is ravaging the young of yemen only the
most critical are taken in here
there are just far too many children to
care for
[Music]
and this is what malnutrition does to a
young body
it strips it down and opens it to
infection
chalmers spent just four years on earth
and there can be few days when she
hasn't been hungry
now she's terribly weak unable to stand
walk or talk
malnutrition destroys the body slowly
and cruelly
sharma's been in hospital for 16 days
already she's much better than when she
first came in
her younger sister has died here in the
year 2020
her mother's now desperately worried
about a second child
dying of starvation
i'm very scared i'm going to lose her
like i lost my other daughter she says
anxious family members wait outside many
have spent the six years of yemen's
civil war
running from the fighting the country is
devastated and it's the children who are
paying for years of political inaction
eighty percent of the population depend
on aid
to live worries over the coronavirus
epidemic
are utterly dwarfed by the fear of
having no food to keep your child alive
and every day here is a battle to keep
on breathing
on every single bed there's a tale of
tragedy
the sheer misery and desperation is
unavoidable
young males gasp for air and hang on by
a thread to life
zaid has cerebral palsy in a country
suffering the world's
worst humanitarian disaster his
condition is made horribly worse by lack
of nutrition
and over-stretched medical facilities
malnutrition babies lead to this
this situation now
little brother is here too but this is
actually better than they used to
they've moved four times to escape
fighting and help is hard to come by
international funding's been cut with
human rights groups
accusing the warring parties of
hampering the aid delivery
and so today they did not give a speech
our tents
we have difficult life also because of
the flooding
our situation is very bad
zayd's father is camped outside on the
hospital pavement
waiting to take his son home he takes us
to see where home is right now
it's a mud and straw hut he's built
himself
held together with discarded plastic
everyone here is in need of help the
malnutrition rates in yemen are amongst
the highest in the world
you're considered amongst the fortunate
if you make it to hospital
and our arrival at this makeshift camp
prompts the young
and the very old and sick to come out
and beg us to highlight their
[Music]
in abs the medics move from one critical
case to another
it's a constant wrestle with death
a tiny scrap of a baby is in trouble
she's so small the oxygen mask almost
covers her entire face
[Music]
but still there yes
but only just they don't want to give up
on this little girl
the gentlest of touches go hand in hand
with the frantic attempts to keep her
breathing
[Music]
by now words got round
every mother here is thinking this could
be her child
but little taif is just not strong
enough 43 days of fighting to live
has finally exhausted her
every life lost here is taken personally
tape's mother is still very much in
shock
and it doesn't get any easier for the
doctors who are seeing this
sometimes several times a day you have
to deal with this
every day this is my life every day
these these are preventable deaths or
they're not
what devastating us most the most
because it's preventable that is not
like inevitable that
it's something that we can't pretend by
only giving
food
but death in yemen is never far away
the level of hunger is unprecedented and
no
comforting will take that pain away
alex crawford sky news in yemen